he's an ex-policeman turned pet
detective who focuses his time on saving
lost or stolen cats but he couldn't do
it alone Colin butcher and his dog Molly
work as a team to reunite missing pets
with their worried families and I'm
delighted to say the pair join me on the
sofa now hello to you Colin and hello to
you Molly who's that really the star of
the show here I should say at Colin say
so how did it all begin
you were a police detective and you
decided to turn your attention to
animals yes
I'd already always got animal cases when
I was in the place and that's really the
thing when Molly was we needed to have a
more effective way of finding missing
and lost cats so the best apprentice to
bring in was a working cocker spaniel so
what is it about Molly
that makes her that the best sidekick
for you I've worked with dogs all my
life lots and lots of working dogs and
her focus is incredible I mean look at
her now and she sees people moving
around yes and as she came into the
studio she was very alert and aware and
sniffing around yeah so her focus is
second to none but she's also very very
personable her ability to connect with
people which is important when we are
out doing investigations that she helps
to bring the anxiety down that people
feeling when the pets are missing so
tell us about some of those
investigations how do you get your work
who calls you and what is it for well we
get calls from people that I've got
missing cats missing parents dogs her my
her area specialization is obviously
cats and she's quite hungry at the
moment they get does that ever give a
traitor yeah yeah so essentially what
we're doing is were a team I bring the
investigative skills and she brings his
amazing nose and between the turbos were
helping owners find their missing in
lost cats all over the country from his
highest Scotland all the way down to
Cornwall and you've written a book Molly
and me and in it you tell some pretty
remarkable stories one of the most
memorable for you we did one on the
Thames which was an incredible
investigation where
the owners contacted us to say that we
they wanted us to help find the cat's
body had fallen off the river barge and
they were short drowned but all cats can
swim and they didn't realize this so it
was more a case of finding out where the
character swam ashore and we're in the
village of Hurley which is just down
from Henley and we searched for three
days and eventually the little cat had
turned up underneath for a caravan on
the river Hurley on the River Thames and
that's where she found and recovered
it's it's quite sweet recovery there
have been some scrapes along the way and
some worrying times for you and Molly
getting bitten by a snake
yes occasion yeah I talk about that in
the book have traumatic that was for me
because she got hit in the chest by a
full-grown adder twice which is very
very rare paralyzed so it was an
emergency trip to the vets and of course
I'm looking at a future where maybe she
won't be around so I'm experiencing what
so many other pet owners have
experienced but after three weeks she
made a full recovery but it was
touch-and-go for a while and back to
work one of the other stories that I
particularly enjoyed was her finding the
treasure trove of jewelry on in
Hampstead was this oh that was an
amazing time we were up there actually
on that occasion we were trying how I'm
looking for a missing dog that we felt
was trapped in a fox earth and she just
deviated off into the woods and she has
the ability that when she's looking for
missing cats she also pick up on a human
scent of the owner so she detected human
scent in the woodland started tunneling
and then ripped out this velvet bag and
in it was all these pearl necklaces gold
rings diamond rings she wants for them
that's why it's Molly and me because
she's saying hey don't forget about me I
am this time here one of the story we've
been talking about today is the health
warnings about affection with dogs and
the impact that that can have on health
and antibiotic resistant bugs I wonder
what you maker of that
I grew up in Malaysia and Singapore and
I've been exposed to animals rescue
animals cats dogs all my life and my
half is great I didn't have any
allergies and I think
it doesn't hurt to have what they bring
into the home at a young age because you
build up your own immunity and perhaps
sometimes well they come hiss hiss
really perhaps sometimes we're a little
bit too precious on our environments
that we live in I think that they bring
so much more good than they do anything
and you to make a formidable team
Colin and Molly thank you both very much
indeed I think Molly's deserving of
another treat